My best tips for getting through immigration controls in the United States.
1st tip,
know 1 minimum of English,
The test will not be done in French.
You have to speak 1 minimum in English and today it is clearly
possible with the applications et cetera So there is no excuse.
Don't panic and be as natural as possible.
If the immigration officer sees that you are not comfortable with your answers,
that you start to stutter,
that you are not sure about your plan and why you come to the United States,
you will pass 1 second check and you will pass 1 bad quarter of an hour.
Answer the questions clearly and simply.
If asked why you are in the United States,
he simply said,
if asked if you have ever visited the United States,
he said yes or no.
Date 7. Also,
If you are going on Insta and planning to go to the U.S. for 3 months,
I advise you to go simply for 85 days,
eighty days,
but not 90 days completely.
The thing is,
if you go away for 90 days completely,
the question may arise as to whether you are
going to immigrate to the United States illegally.
And finally,
last advice,
leave with a minimum of 1 money on your account.
Depending on the state,
this can change of course,
but for example if you go to California for a full 3 months,
then 10,000 on your account it may be fair.
By the way friends I have 1 story time about my brother who
passed immigration controls for the first time in the United States.
And how to tell you that it got a little wet.